دعوه واشنطن لموسكو بالعوده الى معاهده
نيو ستارت للحد من الاسلحه النوويه لن تجد
اذان صاغيه في الكرملين في الوقت الحالي
على الاقل روسيا التي ورثت اسلحه الاتحاد
السوفيتي النوويه تمتلك اكبر مخزون في
العالم من الرؤوس الحربيه النوويه
اتحاد العلماء الامريكيين يقول ان الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين يسيطر على نحو
5977 من هذه الرؤوس الحربيه اعتبارا من
عام 2022
مقارنه مع
5428 يسيطر عليها الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن وتم اخراج نحو 1500 من هذه الرؤوس
الحربيه من الخدمه لكن ربما لا تزال سليمه
وهناك
2,889 في الاحتياط ويتم نشر
1588 كؤوس الحربيه استراتيجيه
التقديرات تقول ان لدى روسيا نحو 400
صاروخ باليستي عابر للقارات مسلحه نوويا
يمكنها ان تحمل ما يصل الى
1185 راسا حربيا روسيا تدير ايضا 10
غواصات مسلحه نوويا يمكنها ان تحمل 800
راس حربي كحد اقصى كما انها تملك ما بين
60 وسبعين قاذفه نوويه
الحرب في اوكرانيا اعادت عقارب الزمن الى
فتره الحرب البارده فتره تسابق خلالها
المعسكران الشرقي والغربي نحو التسلح
حينها امتلك الاتحاد السوفيتي 40 الف راس
فيما امتلكت الولايات المتحده 30 الف بلال
البشتين العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات